enfin en direct avec mme jacques
benillouche il est journaliste
indépendant bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors par
le passé la résolution du conflit
israélo palestinien était considérée
comme une condition sine qua none pour
une normalisation des relations avec les
pays arabes
manifestement ce n'est plus vraiment
d'actualité j'ai certainement pas
d'actualité et je pense que cette
signature à casser la solidarité
interarabe et ça va effectivement créer
deux entités maintenant deux entités
arabe les ceux qui approuvent l'accord
et ceux qui ne l'approuvent pas dans le
dans le camp de ceux qui l'approuvent
pas on peut mettre le qatar est bien
pour la petite histoire je voudrais dire
que cet accord devait être signé ça a
été repoussé alors ça a été repoussée
pour pour une je dirais un incident qui
n'est pas très professionnel la part
d'israël
c'est que de premier ministre n'a pas
voulu amener avec lui son milices des
affaires étrangères gaby ashkenazi est
pour
parce qu'il refuse de mettre en lumière
qui compte dans son gouvernement
eh bien on s'est aperçu quelques temps
quelques temps avant la signature que le
premier ministre n'avait pas qualité
pour signer il n'avait pas l'autorité
pour signer les documents de
reconnaissance et il a dû donc envoyé
demandé à son ministre des affaires
étrangères gaby ashkenazi de lui envoyer
par courrier par mail par photocopie un
pouvoir pour lui permettre de signer ce
si c'était pour la petite histoire et
pour revenir à notre pour revenir à
notre accord
on peut dire qu'il ya quand même deux
probables de questions qui se posent
il a une question d'avoir de sémantique
vous savez la sémantique ans dans les
pays du moyen-orient est très importante
et bien pourquoi il ya cette sémantique
peut intervenir et parce que les émirats
arabes unis vont signer un traité de
paix
ce sont les ce sont les diplomates
israéliens qu'ils nous le disent qu'ils
nous le prévoit par contre est en
revanche le bar n va signer une
déclaration de
et voyez donc une différence qui
existait alors on a peur que ces
déclasser ces différences de ton amène
éventuellement des problèmes
ultérieurement
alors il y a effectivement il ya
effectivement on n'a pas voulu mais on
n'a pas voulu publier les lettres tout
ce qui compte tout ce que comporte cet
accord avant la signature ce qui est
anormal dans un cas pareil
eh bien pourquoi parce que il ya
certaines clauses qui peuvent créer une
mauvaise humeur chez les israéliens
en fait on dit que cet accord sera mis
en oeuvre par étapes afin de garantir
qu'israël n'applique pas sa souveraineté
en cisjordanie avant 2024 cela veut dire
que rien ne pourrait être fait en
cisjordanie par les dix années avant
cette date
alors on dit aussi que les deux pays
n'échangeront pas d'ambassadeur dans
l'immédiat ils commenceront une
coopération économique sécuritaire et
sur les renseignements et ultérieurement
ils échangeront des 100 des ambassadeurs
l'on dit que ce sont les émirats qui ont
imposé ces conditions pourquoi veulent
t'ils les imposer
c'est un moyen pour eux de faire
pression sur les états unis pour qu'ils
achèvent la vente prévue de chassieu
d'avions f-35 qu'israël refuse que les
américains vent alors c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont posé ses conditions et il est
d'ailleurs établi que dans les
négociations netanyahu a aussi accepté
de suspendre son plan de souveraine de
souveraineté sans fixer de date dont
vous comprenez les difficultés qu'il ya
et c'est pour ça qu'on est un petit peu
ici en israël on est un petit peu
inquiets de l'évolution de ces accords
dits accords d'abraham qui effectivement
ont l'avantagé il faut le reconnaître de
marquer un changement bustin dans le
statu quo que nous avons bon on peut
dire simplement que depuis des décennies
les rats sont sont contre israël mais
que cette solidarité a été brisée en
revanche
j'aurai terminé
en revanche les palestiniens n'accepte
pas cet accord et comme toujours il s il
elle essaye de s'opposer à toute
signature tant que leur situation n'est
pas officiellement fixée jacques
benillouche merci pour votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
indépendant